[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh Ryan good to see
you my friend
we're on a high from our last interview
we are we uh I just interviewed Eric
McCormick and Stephen Weber and they
were Dynamite they have a new podcast
and uh they were just awesome they were
so good I can't wait for you guys to
hear it there's a lot of great episodes
of the podcast coming up Carrie Anne
moss and Paula Abdul and Gates McFadden
and the list goes on it's been a great
year I appreciate all your help uh the
patrons are really saving the show
without you guys I couldn't do it go to
patreon.com inside of you and become a
patron and Sport the show I really
appreciate it and if you just want to
listen that's great too I appreciate
that write a review our uh handles right
inside of you pod on Twitter inside of
your podcast on Instagram and Facebook
that's right and reviews really help
also the inside of your online store
tons of great merch new tumblers
Smallville lunch boxes lexmus scripts uh
action figure there's so much good stuff
go to the inside of you online store
I'll probably do a
uh percent off or whatever it's called
discount that's what it's called
um so there's that cons the Tidewater
con Virginia Beach the following weekend
I think that's May
18th or something just look um but
Tidewater Virginia Beach me and wailing
will be there
and a lot of other good stuff a lot a
lot of good cons coming up talk Bill our
podcast is doing really well and thanks
to the patrons again and I'm sorry I
couldn't make it to Wales for uh the con
there I was really looking forward to it
and stuff happened personal stuff and
travel stuff and it just wasn't in the
cards so I know there's a couple you out
there that I really wanted to see that I
was hoping to get to meet for the first
time patrons and uh so and uh yeah
anyway
so that's it we got a great guest Frank
Grillo I love this guy
um I've gotten so many great guests if
you if you have a chance listen to some
other guests even if you don't know them
a lot of people come up and say hey I
didn't know this person but you learn a
lot it's amazing how open and honest he
was about his dad and his dad's death
his mom and dad died right you know to
almost within a week or something you
know from Captain America and one day as
a lion with my buddy Scott Khan It's out
streaming everywhere one day as a line
please check it out it's a cool little
independent tarantino-like movie he was
in Warrior he was so good Nick Nolte
um and he's doing a new DC movie what a
life I met his son his son was here his
son was cool as hell they invite me to
UFC fights I gotta go do one I think
they're not gonna invite me because I
didn't go to the last one but anyway
let's get inside of Frank Grillo it's my
point of view
listening to inside of you Michael
Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know I love how the first
thing you say I meet you for the first
time and I've heard all about you from
like all my friends and people like you
gotta get Frank on the show and the
first thing you're talking about is like
ah you know my divorce I got a new house
and I don't know why what I was thinking
so I do you know you think
you think you learn [__] as you get old
and you should and I've made all the
same mistakes I made when I was young
right uh you know all the same about two
puppies during covid Kane Corsos they're
like Roman guard dogs right because I
had a new girl big dogs gigantic they're
not Pets the only thing I don't like
about big dogs like that is it makes me
sad because they probably don't live
long lives I don't care good
really
if they lived to three that would be
fantastic oh my God he's kidding he's
totally kidding but you love him but
it's like no it's a lot of work I
complicated my life that's what I did
yeah well you know what though I can't
see you or a guy like Michael Bean or a
guy like Robert Patrick these guys that
are tough guys who like I can't see you
with like a poodle no like a lot of
these guys are running around you with a
little white dog no I need a dog like a
punch yeah he's kidding again no but you
want a dog you can wrestle with yeah
have fun with that's like my Blanche I
love to wrestle with her and she just
bites me but it doesn't bite right right
and I got I got two other Sons they stay
at the house by themselves and so my
dogs are there you like you they're
trained I've trained them for a year and
so anybody comes in the house that's not
supposed to be there done they're done
do you have a path of a code word
um no I remember my grandmother uh my
uncle Warren's like this famous animal
trainer he's got like 10 books out he's
like trained Letterman's dogs but she
knows dogs back in the day and uh he had
this dog come over and it was he had it
in the garage and said stay away it was
in a cage just for two days because it
was like you know he didn't want any
trouble with us my grandma I was staying
with my grandmother and I would creep in
as this little boy into the garage and
the dog would look at me and I would
just start trying to guess the names the
password the codes I'd be like doing
German I'm like
[Laughter]
but you know it's funny because I was
originally gonna buy
um a Malamar right because I was in
Israel Malamute
maybe it's a map whatever you know
better night um and I was in Israel
because those were the Israel attacked
like they used them in the Israeli Army
and uh the guy wanted a hundred thousand
dollars you buy the dog and he keeps it
a year and it's a hundred thousand
dollars I'm like what am I Brad Pitt
like where am I that's insane is that
ridiculous and so I got these other two
idiots for seven thousand did you ever
see that is Israeli Army show called
fauda yeah it's one of the best shows
that no one's seen here amazing I keep
wanting to get that guy Leora or
whatever yeah yeah he's like he's like
an old school league almost like a Bruce
Willis yeah character he's a top he's
great that show is awesome
nobody a lot of people don't know about
that show no and Tehran yep those shows
are I know gifts I know like you'll
binge the hell I can't you can't stop
watching you do Benjamin you care about
like all these characters from both
sides yep you're seeing like you know um
so that's great dude I I honestly I
printed out stuff just because I I don't
ever look at [__] hardly but like you
know you've got you've got done so much
so much [__] that it's endless and [__]
is the right word no you were in one of
my favorite movies of all time by the
way is it Malamar
hey yeah yeah
that's either a candy bar or a dog yeah
Malamar no more but like you did one of
my favorite movies and I loved your part
if I'm right
Warrior oh yeah you were the trainer
yeah
so awesome thanks Joe edgerton's trainer
an unknown Joe Edgerton an unknown Tom
Hardy yeah that is another movie
that reviews are off the hook it's
people that when they see it they're
like how have you not seen War I know
it's a movie that's great yeah it caught
a life well after they didn't Market it
they didn't know how to Market it it was
Tom Hardy and Joel on a poster and said
Emma it looked like a fight poster and
MMA wasn't really mainstream right at
that time yeah really like Dana White
hates that movie
hates it why because she feels like it's
not a good representation of Fighters
and and he I did a show a TV series
called kingdom yes um he came to the set
he loved that because we kind of made
that real we kind of made it you know
like the UFC but he hated he Dana White
hates Warrior
is it because it just was kind of flashy
and because I thought it was both I
thought it showed hard-working you know
these guys who were under dogs and like
they have this thing with their dad Nick
Nolte who's amazing that was the movie
you didn't get to work with Nolte though
I didn't but I hung out with him the
whole time he actually changed my life
nicknote how because Nick up until then
I was like I think whatever you know you
learn your lines you go do it and I'm
like whatever I'm doing stupid [__] and
he had this binder now Nick is like the
Mad professor in real life he's smart oh
my God and he's got this giant binder
with like papers and flies and all kinds
of [__] moving around right and I was
like Nick one day I just sat there and
go what are you what is in there what is
in there right I said that's my
character what so I uh over the course
of like two or three months we'll be
there a long time in Pittsburgh
he kind of taught me how to break down a
script the way he does it and the way he
broke down a character in a way he and
it was and he still does it and he still
does it it changed my career it changed
my life it changed the way I looked at
acting I thought acting was kind of
silly I still do but I understand I
understand how to do it in in a far
deeper way because of Nick Nolte and he
got nominated for an Oscar in that movie
yeah yeah but it's amazing that you
actually wanted to take that advice to
take that sort of work ethic yeah you
know because that that takes another
level like do you want to work that hard
because like you go on set you deliver
your lines you're always good like you
know what else what do I need natural
yeah making money I got kids I got a
life right you know right so the fact
that you said hey I'm gonna do that and
now you do this for every movie yeah
deep and by the way I've I've kind of
almost like like it's almost got me in
trouble on several occasions because I
figure everybody should be working this
way I got neurotic about it you know and
now I've cooled out a bit because who
cares and uh but it really was it really
became an interesting way to work it was
really a lot of fun and you realize how
many people are lazy when you are the
guy doing the work wow yeah how many
actors show up looking at sides like
they're looking at their lines you're
like oh oh you didn't read this like you
didn't really or they're learning in the
makeup trailer yeah I see that all the
time oh you know I know especially you
do that you you being on a show that was
on so long everybody's coming through
there yeah and you get to see you know
yeah I've dude I have been on set where
I don't know if I've told the story you
would know as our editor Jason Jason's
here folks but uh I remember somebody
who has like their royalty and I'm not
gonna say anything else but they just
they just couldn't they didn't know
their lines at all and to the point
where I go hey dude we do this all the
time check this out and I stuck the
sides to my face on this close-up
and I guess are you serious it's
embarrassing I go no because no one sees
it the performance accounts that's right
and I sat there with on my face stuck to
my sweaty forehead and he read the lines
good on you about by the way I've worked
with some uh Legends yeah and um I have
to tell you more than three of them or
at least three of them
earwigs and cute cards I want to do that
I know I want to go on it's not easy
it's not easy to do it I did a movie
called The Gray with uh Liam with Nissan
and uh yeah listen to me and uh and uh
Carnahan wanted to put an earwig in mic
because I was dying at the end and he
wanted to throw me lines I went yeah all
right put it in it's a whole skill set
to be able to listen to what someone's
saying re and repeat it on top of that
on top of that in a way where you're
convincing
it is
but and also can you you sure you can
hear it is there an interruption do I
look on camera like I'm waiting for you
to say something so I can say do you
know what I mean like you have to
understand the physiological part of the
whole thing like how is my body behaving
while I'm being read along but you
didn't have a chance to really rehearse
no no that's a different Joe is just
yelling right so apparently Robert
Downey Jr and a bunch of people do stuff
where they have this and it's just like
they practice like I would with Jason I
go all right go ahead if you need the
lines and probably film myself do me and
go okay that's good that's good that's
good and it also creates a spontaneity
you're hearing the lines for the first
time and you're like you're not thinking
about it and and you know uh yeah look I
don't I don't know how other people feel
about it on set when they're dealing
with somebody who's doing that but
you've dealt with a lot yeah yeah and
listen sometimes it works sometimes it's
silly but and then I've worked I
recently worked with uh Keitel and uh
you know he's 80 something years old
like 81 years old and so so he had to
you know he had the ma he said do you
mind if I put the monitor behind you I'm
like brother you're RV Keitel do
whatever you want to do and you know and
he I could see he struggled a bit like
having to do it yeah but that's more of
a guy who's just you know he's been
around a long time and and it's probably
a little difficult to remember stuff I
can't remember stuff yeah well you know
the uh Beverly D'Angelo just posted this
she's a good friend of mine she's such
an amazing woman she's she's insane I
love her right yeah she's talking about
Christmas vacation you know that whole
speech where Chevy Chase goes
everybody's got any last minute gift
ideas I have one I want french Shirley I
don't want him brought over from his
holiday Slumber over a Medley Lane with
other rich people with a big ball in his
neck I want to look him in the eye and
tell him no good worthless heartless
farted monkey ass [__] they had like
every actor on the set had like a cue
card on their chest and he would read it
off are you kidding yeah and it was
awesome you never would have thought
that never would have thought it I I I
did a movie called
um a Wheelman and I was basically me in
a car for for you know 88 minutes that
had to be like well the last day we had
a hiccup that we we lost a couple of
days so I had one day to do 35 pages
30 I I kid you not 35 pages in one day
and Joe was like all right let's not try
to do this I said you know what
I got this I said I think I could do it
are you still under the lines I'm in a
car and I think we took no more than two
takes and I did all 35 pages and it's a
great movie and I'm I'm not blowing
smoke on my ass it's a great little
movie and you can't tell you can't tell
where it was in the movie that I had
really yep but you know you use cue
cards no you just knew it I knew it I
knew it I kind of knew this circumstance
and and I I almost word for word so if
you you know if you want to do the work
right you can do the work yeah that's
true you do the one now you do the work
thanks to Nick nolteon
by the way I just always loved Liam
Neeson is he a good guy to work oh my
God and he became a great he was a great
drinking buddy like the gray right yeah
yeah we were both we you know he's a big
dude he's like six six and uh we would
kill six bottles of wine him and I and
we would walk back to our hotel and I
would have to carry I need to Lean on Me
Liam on you
Liam on me
inside of you is brought to you by neuro
hacker qualia
qualia remember that name I'm going to
tell you why I take this product every
morning I have one medication
I have qualia the neuro hacker
and I don't miss it and the story really
behind this guys is that I didn't
realize they were a sponsor because I
hadn't done reads but I proved them
because I did research but then it was
it took a while and I had this product
that was sent to me and I thought oh I
probably ordered ordered it on Amazon
and I started taking it for about a
month and then I started getting reads
and I go wait a minute
and I noticed a difference
in my memory in my sharpness
and I have not stopped taking it
I am through a bottle a bottle and a
half
um I really enjoy this product and it
was inadvertent
um that's the word of the day
inadvertent I didn't even know I was
taking it it was that PR and it works
for me and I know it will work for you
our sponsor neuro hacker combines 28 of
some of the most researched-backed
nootropic ingredients on Earth
into an ultimate brain fuel formula
qualia mind and it's been changing
people's lives for years now look for
for help with my daily mental
performance and help supporting my
long-term brain health I think while
your mind is indispensable it just is
it's it's cool to see a product you know
where you don't have to wonder if it's
working because I noticed the difference
like I said within a week I was sharper
the formula is non-GMO vegan gluten free
and the ingredients are meant to
complement one another factoring in each
ingredient's effect on supporting mental
Clarity it's also backed by a hundred
day guarantee there you go all right
you have almost three months to try
neuro hackers call your mind at no
Financial Risk and decide for yourself
see what one of the best brain fuel
formulas on Earth can do for your
mindset go to neurohacker.com IOU for 75
off that's only thirty nine dollars a
bottle and as a listener of inside of
you use the code IOU at checkout for an
extra 15 off your purchase that's
neurohacker.com ilu to try qualiamind
with code IOU to experience
life-changing mental performance the
products and statements are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease this show is sponsored by
betterhelp when you're at your best you
can do great things but sometimes life
gets you bogged down and you may feel
overwhelmed or like you're not showing
up in the way you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you and who couldn't use a few
better coping skills to be able to
handle all of life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
I can just see him drunk it's like oh
I'm so drunk now I can't ah look at that
Irish oh thank you we should have one
more scoop we should I'm like yeah Liam
you're Liam Neeson we could have as many
scoops as you want how is he the next
day oh he's fine
what a constitution and then he stopped
he just stopped he just quit he quit
drinking yeah do you drink I stopped uh
Christmas
really yeah good for you I drank for
about 40 years uh just wine mostly a
little bit of tequila but I drank my son
in the other room we did it together we
drank a bottle bottle and a half
sometimes two bottles every night you
know just kind of shooting [__] I drank
a lot of wine sometimes I'd go to work
and there's wine in my trailer like I
drank you know I drink Rose and red well
weren't you worried that he was going to
become an alcoholic I needed somebody to
drink with so you said I'm gonna use my
son yeah he was great at it he was good
but he's not a big drinker now I don't
not in the house he won't drink in front
with me anymore they want in front of me
no no respect he's like I want you to be
fine I think he feels better I think how
do you feel though do you feel better I
have to tell you so I I got a stomach
bug before Christmas so I didn't drink
for a few days and then I really felt
good
and then there's this thing dry January
so I'm like let me give this a shot
because I really feel better like I need
to kind of clean myself and I train
every day for like two hours with
professional fighters and Jiu-Jitsu I
sweat boxes boxing a box and I wear a
sauna suit so I mean I sweat all day you
know all when I train and I thought I
felt good but I didn't drink and I felt
really great and dry January turned into
just I'm fine I do enjoy psilocybin
you know what Theo Rossi was talking
about that it is a game changer right do
micro dose what does that make you feel
like I'll tell you what it does first of
all talk about Clarity you feel
incredibly clear
um far more emotionally stable and you
there's an overall feeling of positivity
which I you know that's because you're
tripping I'm not sure no you don't trip
unless you take copious amounts of it
right but I I do the micro dosing like
I'll do before I go to how many
milligrams you even know I think it's
three milligrams every day or off you go
up one day I don't do it every day no no
no there's no reason to you know but uh
you know I'll do it before I go to gym
I'll do it before I go out so that I
know people are drinking that I just
because I I have to tolerate now the
people who are I'm that guy you know
what I mean yeah it's been it's been
great my kids like I'm far more
level-headed and and uh less reactive
really yeah man see I'm telling you I I
for memorization you're clear clear all
right I'm gonna email you or you can
give me your phone number probably
because I live near you yeah I want you
to send me what you take and where you
get it I'll drive it over I listen I
want to try it but I'm really sensitive
with drugs I don't do drugs I don't want
to be like I've never done cocaine
I will drop a box a bar off tomorrow you
tell me what you think a bar yeah it's a
bar of chocolate you just take a little
square and you tell me in the morning or
whenever if I get nauseous oh my God you
sound like my mother a bit of a puss
well when I get nauseous well I get
nauseous then I'm gonna take you dry I
don't want to get nauseous
because I'm gonna call you Anthony
Frankie and Francis
my mother who arrested so she used to
call me oh she's passed oh she died
right before covered um she used to call
me Kiki it was my nickname so I grew up
Kiki
you let anybody else call you Kiki not
anymore not anymore what about that is
he around dad died uh short Dad kind of
killed himself after she died I was on a
movie this is only like three years ago
this was like about three and a half
years ago yeah three years ago oh my God
I'm doing a movie for Sony in uh in New
Orleans talked to my mother in the
morning
I get back to my house in uh in New
Orleans and my phone rings it's my
sister and she's screaming something
about my mother and then she hung up the
phone
and she called me back five minutes
later and she said she's gone she's gone
my mother had come home from food
shopping literally looked at my father
and fell down and died
and we we didn't have an autopsy but I
think it was like maybe an aneurysm or
something in her stomach she had stomach
problems but yeah she was 72 young
that's young now yeah and a young 72. my
mother was a great human being if she
hadn't married my father she'd be a much
better person uh really yeah but then my
father was a lifelong alcoholic
killed himself with booze like within
the next four weeks just drank himself
today to death he tried to stop him put
himself in a coma you know what can you
do yeah what are you gonna do stop no he
was chronic he was a chronic alcohol and
he was he losing her was everything that
was all yeah they hated each other for
50 years yeah but they were married they
realized how much he loved her when she
passed yeah yeah yeah she they had me
when they were like 18 years old
my God was your were your parents good
growing up no no they weren't they're a
mess they were like a mess they were
unevolved they were my father was an
immigrant from Italy like they they had
no idea what they were doing man
difference I'm sure Italian I'm not
saying like tough guy bro oh my God so
he wasn't like it I love you no well no
he was affectionate but oddly
affectionate like almost like he was
hyper emotional he couldn't control his
emotions yeah I grew up in a like anger
or both crying both both yeah both of
those really yeah
so it wasn't fun growing up no it was
and I was the oldest so it was uh it was
a tough tough go of it when I was
growing up emotionally do you know what
I mean it was just chaos it was chaos I
I know I know like I I remember when I I
met my friend
uh who lived across the street from me
uh they had a check and I was like
what's that he's like what's a check
what do you mean what's that like my
parents never had a checking account
they never had a bank account they paid
everything with money orders you know
the electricity was going off all the
time I remember my mother always rushing
to the uh to where you pay the electric
bill you know oh my God you know I can't
say how many nights I had Captain Crunch
for dinner
it was could have been worse could have
count chocolate
you know Fruity Pebbles fruity I like
Fruity Pebbles you drink the milk it's
all sugary fruity yeah but I'll tell you
you know all of that has has uh has has
made me uh crazy well you know what you
know they they do your product of your
own environment so you try to take the
good yeah from both if whatever there is
and the bad you really
what happens to me is I through life I
have seen part of like the bad sides and
I get really mad at myself and depressed
when I when I see that right and then I
try to correct those and go no I'm not
going to do that I'm going to go in the
other opposite direction so I find
myself really hard on myself to try and
make up for the things that maybe I
didn't get or maybe that whatever or you
thought you should have got and you know
there's also that idea of what we think
we should have right but you know it's
the same thing but you always have to be
kind to you like what I learned I always
say you must be kind to yourself yeah
it's the last words of every podcast I
said please be good to yourself you got
to I I'm really trying I'm trying to do
that it's so hard because I could say
you're such an [__] I know you're
such why did you do that well you
weren't the best this well why take your
[__] dog for another walk every
[__] thing upsets me I know why don't
you read that script it's your friend's
script I know I don't want to read
another friend's script me either I
don't want to give notes stop I don't
care I don't want to care but I
and then I judge myself based on my very
worst moments like you know what I mean
when I got one I first got separated I
had a girlfriend who was maybe the most
beautiful girl I've ever seen in my life
right and she was my girlfriend she was
really cool you'd probably get the
ladies
you're a fighter
she was cool for three months and then
it and then she wasn't cool and she
knew how to press all of those buttons
about myself about how I felt about
myself she was a genius she told her
yeah
Machiavelli would have came back and
like said oh my God oh my God I love you
yeah it was amazing and and that's when
I was like oh I need to I need to take a
minute away from women like I need uh to
be alone with myself did you go to
therapy I did man and I haven't changed
your life yeah therapy and then I have
another another guy uh my buddy Peter
Evans in uh in Santa Monica
he's a breathing healer and and through
does that really work oh man because I
tried it once and I couldn't get through
recession it was so much breathing no
this he sends you it's like doing
Ayahuasca without doing ayahuasca it
sends you into he's in a trance this guy
won an Olympic gold medal when he was 19
then disappeared into India and he came
out and he had all this knowledge right
and he and he's everyone goes to him
what kind of breathing can you get an
example in five reps so for instance
you'll do you'll sit up straight and
you'll take 10 deep breaths so you
almost hyperventilate and he'll and
he'll no deep right and he'll be talking
to you and he's playing certain music
it's all very kind of you know a little
spiritually right that kind of music and
he's talking to you and probably you've
before that have spoken to him about
what's been on your mind or whatever it
is and then he starts touching parts of
your body hard and soft and you're
holding your breath and then he says
breathe out and then he pounds your
liver
and literally you go out
you pass out and you shake right and you
start to see [__] it's like Ayahuasca
and then you wake up and it's like you
were just born again I know this sounds
you cry emotional so many times
because one day I'm sitting there and it
goes off on you know I never got to say
goodbye to my mother and so it might be
that right and I am the most cynical New
York guy that you could imagine yeah I I
think everyone is full of [__] yeah
especially most people are that's why
it's hard most people are right they're
opportu most people are opportunist
without even realizing it this man has
apps I have sent dozens of people there
people that you know and I know like
people that everyone knows and uh Game
Changer I think I'm scared of like as
vulnerable as I can be like on the
podcast and talk about [__] like letting
go and and losing control and crying and
stuff like that that scares me baby it's
scary but that's what you need you know
what I mean because you think you're in
control you think because you're holding
this thing together you're in control
right that's what it's creating all
these problems we're not in control
we're afraid
do you know yeah I've had a couple of
about a year this is great but we're
good right you're watching it this is
good [__] oh okay it's cut by the way
cut me off no okay this is exactly what
I want I'm like oh this is heaven
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72 hour sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant wherever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
I had a year ago my my one of my best
friends was my manager his name is Chris
euvane uh his brother's Kevin euvane who
runs CAA like very prominent family
killed himself shot him spoke to him on
the phone he was going through
depression serious depression uh we were
going to take him to a new facility on
on Monday very successful manager
Chadwick Boseman Margot Robbie like this
guy was the [__]
everyone loved this kid right had
everything to live for and uh so I spoke
to him the night before he killed
himself and I said I'm taking you to
Peter uh this this Thursday he was
coming back
he killed himself the next day right
oh it was devastating gutted like took
six months for me to recover so I could
even function this guy I spoke to him 30
times a day but he was very vocal about
being depressed right and he couldn't he
could not get a hold of it he couldn't
so I it's the first time I've witnessed
what mental health mental sickness
mental illness really is do you know
what I mean this guy had all the money
in the world very powerful came from a
family that was runs Hollywood and was
beloved you know helped everybody paid
it forward and wasn't happy wasn't happy
right beyond happy like joyless which is
worse like going through the motions of
life and and and and being vocal about
not getting anything back from it do you
know what I mean yeah so six months go
by and I have I grew up in a house with
my father's brother's kids too we all
grew up together so there was there was
eight of us all mostly all boys there
was only two girls and and um my closest
cousin who I grew up with my it was my
brother was getting divorced blah blah
blah girl moved to Montana kids
California Montana long story comes to
my house on a Thursday and he's down
right he just turned 60. uh and he was
really down
um and I I uh oh no a week before he
came to my house I sent him to Peter
he came out of Peter and he said I I
don't know what that is he said but I've
never felt like this in my life I have a
clear path
to what I need to do and I'm going to go
to Montana and tell Pauline and I'm
going to stay in California and I think
I I gotta hang thank you so much and
Peter had called me and then he came to
my house the following week he was going
to Montana he went to Montana and he's
very vulnerable very an empathic guy and
she was not kind to him and
she she said some things to him and he
killed himself the same way that my
friend Chris did shot himself
and that oh my God is that so much loss
well and in a specific way like mental
illness and that put me on a path
to help anybody and everybody like if
you who I don't know told me just now
that you were going through some like
whatever I can do to help any stranger
who tells me that they're suffering
that's kind of been my thing
um I don't know how I got off on this
team no but I'm talking about your
friend's death yeah killing yourself
you're talking about the breathing yeah
now that you're about to get him into
that and then this happened right before
which is devastating you know it's so
funny because I've talked about this but
doing this podcast I I wasn't uh you
know somebody's like you got a great
voice you should do podcasts man you
should have your own you know interview
celebrity so make money I'm like all
right cool and I started doing it I was
like man no one's really listening no
one's you know and I was just kind of
like you know whatever and then I
started to be vulnerable
and I started to speak openly spoke
openly about my depression anxiety my
life everything yeah and get started
open up crying everything and now I just
went to a con in in Chicago I don't even
promote the con or promote the podcast
one of my cons or anything right
if I told you how many people came up to
me saying
it means so much to me your podcast I'm
like and I'm like why Wow but hearing
other people that have had huge success
right and them all being vulnerable and
them being like hey you know I and it
just helps so many people when you just
talk about it that's right I do it on my
Instagram a lot and and I can't it's the
same thing so many people come up and
say man you're an inspiration and thank
you for just kind of showing that being
a human being yeah that kind of
vulnerability and and uh you know I I
it's amazing because it's not a path
that I was imagining ever being on or or
caring that much about again trying to
control my my life but uh you know it's
it's it's been
um it's been revelatory to kind of
accept you know the pain of it all of
life life is you know and as I get older
you know you kind of you now I'm marking
time more like you know I'm running out
of time you know what I mean we always
are from the day we're born we're dying
yeah and then you but you get to a
certain point you're like oh wait a
minute people are dying in my life like
they're they're dying like it's not you
know so it's it's interesting that I you
know you start to be cognizant of
your mortality and and then and and then
you know and then we're gone so you know
I think I think creating a community uh
you know especially dudes I always say
this like men need to stick together
yeah like guys need to take care of each
other yep you know I'm good friends with
like Pete Berg you know Pete the
director I love him Pete's great right
we boxed together and and uh but we were
in a sauna one we were in the sauna
together after we were training and we
were talking and and we I was getting in
the middle of my divorce which was the
worst time of my life and worse than my
parents death was my divorce and I was
sitting there we were talking and he's a
little bit older than me but but uh he
said I'm gonna tell you something
guys in their 50s need to stick together
he said you know whatever you need come
and talk to me you know come and I it it
dawned on me that as we get older men
become more and more isolated right like
especially the old school right you know
like my cousin And even Chris uh you
vein like he was vocal about the
depression but he really became he
isolated himself and that's what men
tend to do so it's you know you gotta
sometimes you gotta drag people you know
I know you gotta drag people out I know
I try I mean it's a it's a fine line
like well it's a thin line between like
enabling and helping so some people if
they don't want to be helped there has
to come a time you're like I'm wasting
my time and your time because you just
aren't wanting this yeah they're
despondent it's it's a test it's a
tragedy I have tried there's yeah I've
tried so many times and I then I
realized how many weeks years hours
whatever it is I've spent on certain
people like of my own time because I
care so much and it's almost like you're
wasting your time yeah and sometimes
I've just cut it off like I'm talking
you know I like I never really talked
about it but like
you know I love my brother he's amazing
he's an you know amazing guy smarter
smart as hell smarter than I am
people love me it's fun to be around
he's just a great guy but he has some
things that he like doesn't want to deal
with right and I have tried and tried
and I have seen it right in front of me
and I have seen like and I and there's
and and that's your brother and that's
my brother and it's like now
i i as bad as it feels I'm just like I
love you always here for you yeah I'm
not I'm not asking you about this I'm
not telling you I'm not gonna start
telling you how to live your life if you
don't want to take advice if you don't
want to listen to me or if you don't
wanna then I I can't do it anymore it's
the smartest in my heart yeah it's
killing me and then you and then you
have animosity towards him you know like
because he's not doing what you think he
should be doing right to help himself
and he'll say certain things in front of
me which is is a button layer yeah well
he'll say a trigger yeah like who cares
man I'm just gonna go all out who cares
what happens right right kind of thing
like yeah you know what's funny
everybody cares you know Jordan Peterson
says a great thing
um he says uh
um never underestimate the hold that you
would leave if you weren't here right
and my cousin who shot himself you know
his kids were in the other room it's
three kids right and his uh ex-wife
uh he he destroyed the family he
destroyed he destroyed us you know it
destroyed us it it just devastated our
family and his kids are going to suffer
for a long time and it's like and then
you know he was a he was a crucial my
family is very close all of us the
brothers and cousins and he you know he
devastated what was he was a crucial
part of the anatomy of it all and it's
gone so what do you say about that like
you know you hear these things like
Robin Williams and he hung himself and I
I always say like my thought is we don't
know how dark one is to do something so
tragic and so unlike them and to do it
maybe in the Next Room right that it's
it's a sickness it's such an emotional
that it does everything and nothing
matters but the task in hand yeah and
you gotta You Gotta Throw logic you know
because we're trying to fade well how
could you do that with your well if I'm
sitting here in the right mind having a
logical conversation of course it
doesn't make sense but obviously he
wasn't in his right mind right yeah he
was delusional and it's just tragic yeah
it's freaking tragic it is and I just
like I always if you ever do this I
dwell on this sometimes not as much
anymore but like I'll I'll think
how will I feel if this person passes
how would I deal with it and you don't
Linger on it like a cranberry song right
but you like you kind of like you sit
there and go okay how would you feel
would you be able to deal with it oh my
God then you start to feel the
overwhelming kind of like you put
yourself in that situation it's almost
like acting preparing for you yeah it is
acting and you yeah and you kind of like
going but you never can prepare for it
never prepare for how are you're going
to feel and it's just of course you're
terrifying you just can't you can't you
can't keep dwelling no you can imagine
you can imagine
which is a logical intellectual thing
how you would feel which is not has
nothing to do with your intellect right
but you could imagine how you would feel
right because every time I thought I was
gonna feel something I had a really
tumultuous relationship with my with my
father was it abusive it was it was
verbally and and uh you know I was a
strong kid by the time you were
wrestling at eight right yeah I would
you know so he wasn't gonna mess with
you no he walked around me like I was
nuts too so you know no I was always
like worried he was gonna hit my mother
so I was I was always around you know
and he knew right um and he didn't if he
couldn't defend himself against a double
egg takedown so what was he gonna do
right right um or the cross face cradle
I wrestled too Jason
but but you know when he went into the
hospital so he went into an
alcohol-induced coma and and I had to
fly back to New York and my brother and
I and my my eldest cousin my cousin Roy
sister we were in the hospital for a
week he was intubated and stuff and I
thought that if my father had died I had
said it many times before you know well
if you don't want to be alive die you
know I don't care
that's not the truth you know I sat
there holding his hand talking to him
crying like I didn't know if he could
understand me and I didn't want him to
be afraid you know what are we most
afraid of of when we're alive is dying
so imagine if I don't know that his
brain was awake but his body was shut
down and he was looking like sometimes
he'd open his eyes and look at me and I
was like pop can you see me pop blink
you know can you see me and His Hands
would move and I'd want to believe he
was squeezing my hand right and I didn't
want him to die alone that was my fear I
didn't want him to know that I want them
to know I was there and that whatever
happened in the past was was okay point
being if you had told me that's that
that would have been me
thank you that scares the [__] out of me
it's an interesting thing no you're
right though you're absolutely right
it's one of those things where your
friends probably said hey get Grillo on
he's fun to talk to you are by the way
you know in a sense that you know you
said your father was always emotional
you could cry it would scream you would
do whatever yeah like how do you feel
like like with Remy I see this great kid
in the other room he's just full of life
he's an actor he's got a movie coming
out what's the movie he's a director he
directed him he directed a movie it's
called the resurrection of Charles
Manson it's out now in all the streamers
what I I how old is he he's 20 who's 25
when he did it right out of film school
and he listen he and the first cut of it
was horrific he had a lot of [__] to do
every first Cuts horrific horrific and
my buddy Gavin O'Connor who directed
Warrior we gave he watched it with me we
gave him notes and Remy went back for
three months and cut the movie in a way
uh that was really cool and creepy and
people love love this little kind of
joke what's it called
now my question was
do you feel like you know you're like
affectionate with him like you said I
love you so much oh they have to kiss me
good night they have to that my son is
she cried to him my son's 26 when he
leaves the house he has to tell me where
he's going when he gets there he tells
me he's landed when he's leaving the
house that he's at he has to tell me
he's so Italian I'm sorry are you
smothering him I'm smothering him and I
said does he tell you that no he just
gives me a look but I have three sons
and I am I am also hyper effect I love
them to the point where they're saying
stop you can't kiss me when you drop me
off at Pally high
are they rebellious at all have any of
them no no no no no they're good they're
all good boys they really are my my
middle one is uh uh on the Spectrum
um so he's a little kooky he's a little
he's a little like when he talks he
sounds like Borat like he's he it's not
that he says the wrong things he just
says them in a way that sounds like he
might be a foreigner
he's got a language processing thing
he's beautiful and so they've all
they're all just really great kids I've
been blessed with great kids they have a
great mother or both of them they have
two different mothers
um I've been I've been are you still
friends with them oh yeah yeah yeah even
the one that like you were devastated
oh yeah yeah we're we're great friends
in fact her mom I'm like really like
Debbie Downer her mom is passing right
now she just had a stroke she's in Rhode
Island and my my ex-wife Wendy had a
terrible relationship with her and she
was debating on whether to go and today
I had a long conversation I said listen
uh you should get on a plane I'll take
the kids to get on the plane for your
soul for your soul go there and and just
sit with your mother I said the other
thing is if she's alone and she's
cognizant and she knows she's alone and
that's the last thing
you don't want that and so she's going
on a plan she's gonna go and and see her
mother you know so yeah so we're we
we're back it took us three years I was
devastated like she broke your heart
well no it was my fault I I made a
terrible error and uh that was not
fixable and you tried to yeah I tried to
I tried to and it just you know when
when when it's just fractured that much
did you learn from it oh my God they say
you don't learn like I I that happened
to me years ago where I let the love of
my life sort of go like because of
selfish reasons right and I just was
like oh yeah you know and
when I try to get her back
she was with somebody right and it was a
I've never felt like that so when you
hit rock bottom and when you do it
because of an action that you are that
you you were the responsible person it
just it's devastating devastating and
that's the only way sometimes people
change when they truly lose something
that's so close to them and it's their
fault maybe then that's the moment where
they're right away yeah and that's where
me that was me and I was the guy you
know there's a little part of your brain
I think it's next to the amygdala where
there's an Amiga amygdala which is the
fight or flight oh the amygdala
um but there's another place not far
from there that will uh allow you allows
us to justify things that we do right
that's part of your brain and I had a
very strong that was very strong in my
brain yes strong amygdala yeah next to
the amning I forgot the name of that
part of the brain
um you know the amygdala no that should
be a movie called next to the amygdala
about a guy who can't control himself
shave your head you're the guy amen
I love it anyway I did a lot of that as
a as a stupid guy you know always making
justifying my stupidity yeah and I've
learned from from my my divorce uh now
not to do that not first of all not to
do stupid things that I know are stupid
you know don't don't be a pleasure
Seeker well do you think a lot of these
actions happened I I find if you look at
like the bats uh things that we do in
life the bad mistakes
if you're a drinker probably has
something to do a drink
bam it always does I mean you're not
clear you make the best period and
brother I I started to kind of back
think about it when I wasn't
drinking right not necessarily drunk
because I wasn't a drunk like I didn't
you didn't I wasn't still a buzz still
something to make you go this feels like
fun here you go there you go that's it
yep that's I think you know
yeah I have someone in my life that
that's like you know once that happens
it opens the floodgates yeah they never
would have done certain things I know
and you do things that just can
devastate other people I notice about
myself now like I don't react like I'm
dealing with this house and it's you
know I joke about it like I paid a lot
of money for the house and now I'm
paying a lot of money to fix the house
do you know do you know what I mean yeah
there's gonna be some kind of insurance
that covers it doesn't cover
um building defects and so this is a
building defect so I could either choose
to litigate like then I'm paying three
four five hundred thousand dollars to
litigate the owner and the Builder and
uh you know or I guess what about the
person who came and looked at the house
and made sure everything was okay sue
him the the the the
um inspection inspection but they
couldn't see it because it was hidden
inside of they only can inspect what
they can inspect like what they can see
right and all the house has great bones
but in any event
um I would have probably killed somebody
like I you know normally I'm a hot head
but I'm not as a hot head as I thought I
was
from not drinking like I've been a lot
calmer and I just realized that it's
amazing because I look at you and if you
have like you're obviously your arms are
huge you're all tatted out you're
handsome as far but if I'm a big dude at
some bar and you're in there and you got
a shirt on like you're like [__] this
guy I'm sure people probably didn't
realize all the training and how much
ass you could probably kick oh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean I've been in a lot
of fights have you had those are you let
me ask you something are you Fearless
when you get in a fight or do you get
nervous or no I don't get nervous I know
that you know that's the first thing
when you learn to fight is you learn to
control your breath and your heart rate
and so the first thing you do is relax
and I can tell in two seconds if you
this person doesn't know what they're
doing yeah and I can tell exactly I know
exactly what you're gonna do I could
just like look in the middle you're just
gonna go for a punch in the face or grab
the throw so whatever they're gonna do
it's you know and you uh you know
obviously at this point in my life I
don't want to fight but but uh yeah I
know how to fight I mean whatever it's
like it's like being a mechanic like
you've done it so much that you're so
much you're Fearless though there's
something there's got to be something
really good to feel like you're not
scared
to be like if somebody's at your door
somebody's in the backyard if you're
like not a traffic stop and goes hey I'm
gonna get a car and kick your ass to
have that kind of relaxed sort of like
no you're not no I'd love to have that
pull over have you said that oh my God
you get out yeah of course you kick
somebody's ass oh yeah quickly quickly
quickly yeah are they surprised like
holy [__] yeah I mean you know most
people don't know how to fight like they
could be they'll be tough guys or they
can be bit you know there's a lot of
buff people but that has nothing to do
with you know the toughest guys I know
don't lift weights really so but you
know I I that's not why I love fighting
like I did I did a docu series for
Netflix called fight world and because I
was in Anthony Bourdain fanatic right
and so I don't bring up his death oh man
devastated yeah yeah but I took his
format and I instead of fight culture
and food culture I I got into fight
culture and I traveled around because I
wanted to understand the what what makes
people want to fight do you know because
it goes against your nature to fight it
really does I mean human beings are
meant to run away you know
um what is it it's I I don't the only
through line that I really found was
most of the countries that I went to and
I went to Israel and Myanmar and and
Thailand and and Brazil most of these
are impoverished
you know nothing to lose nothing to lose
and it's a way to just kind of get out
and that's it becomes part of the
culture much like soccer in many places
you learn to be tough you learn to be
like nothing's gonna affect right you're
not gonna scare me I live with rats you
know what I mean yeah like I you know
I'm on the precipice of dying every day
yeah you know what do you got what do
you got yeah so those are the guys you
don't want to fight yeah you don't man
because they don't fight for points they
you know like I went to Israel and you
know they're surrounded by no no 23
hostile Nations you know what I mean
they went through a lot Israel and they
still do and and uh you know barring
whatever politics you have I mean these
people you know it's about the dirt
you know so there's nothing you're
really gonna do yeah they've seen it
yeah you know they're it's about
protecting that dirt and their kids you
know and never again looking down and
letting in so there's that Fearless kind
of thing yeah you know what's let me ask
you this what is like if you were to get
in a fight not you yeah proverbial you
yeah me yeah Jason guys that really
don't fight I've been in fights I've
lost more than I've won
but how long are these fights that
you've lost
um
they weren't they didn't last long yeah
I mean they're not they're flash fights
I call yeah it might last three minutes
yeah well that's not bad that's a good
fight yeah I was exhausted in three
that's the other thing when you're
stamina yeah when you're fighting what
happens is you're adrenaline your
adrenaline comes talk about the amygdala
um your fight or flight kicks in and now
you're fighting right you don't know how
to breathe when you fight unless you're
a fighter unless you know unless you've
learned how to control your breath your
breath controls your your heart rate so
once your heart starts pumping blood and
your breath is you're short breathing
right you're you're almost gonna
hyperventilate if you keep fighting you
have to know how to relax
take a punch so you could do it
inadvertently subconsciously you're
already doing that of course of course
yeah but what if somebody like me if
somebody want to fight and I had to
what's the one place you go to if you
had to fight if you had to tell somebody
look man you're gonna you're gonna get
hit anyway you might as well [__] if you
could hit first yeah I mean you know you
want to go for the soft tissue you know
you you you you know you want to hurt
some so you have to be willing to also
hurt somebody you know you want you want
to stick somebody like in Israel they do
Krav Maga which is whatever's available
use whatever is available it's violent
and fast and that's what you want to be
if you get into a fight violent and fast
you know it's not like I'm gonna try to
punch you in the face you know you know
what's worse than getting punched in the
face getting punched in the liver which
is right under your rib on the right
side of your body you punch somebody in
the liver within about two seconds it
releases every toxin that's inside of it
and the person will drop down to us have
no control over his faculties just right
under there right on the right side not
even hard
so if you know what about in the throat
yeah I mean but you have to be able to
you know because just naturally people
will drop their chin so how are you
gonna throw like this yeah yeah and
people do that yeah come on yeah yeah
the tough guys will come and go like
that well they used to and yeah yeah but
you know look fighting's horrible it's
when it's not controlled it's painful
you know it is it's painful yeah you
know it hurts a lot when the adrenaline
kind of goes away and and uh have you
lost fights um street fights
not one-on-one but if there's two or
three guys maybe yeah I've had a couple
of fights where there was with bouncers
and stuff and they you know they got the
the better the better of me because
there was more of them yeah you lose
some teeth no you know I gotta tell you
I'm a Grappler and I know how to throw
my hands so I'm I'm okay in both places
I'm I'm a wrestler so I'm I'm good on my
back from Jiu Jitsu and you know I do it
all so I know how to handle myself uh
you know I and unless I'm fighting
Donald Cerrone or you know George
St-Pierre I'm fine but as someone ever
just thrown a punch and you were like oh
yeah but you know you I naturally roll
like just from from fighting you know if
you throw a punch me I move my head
you're probably gonna miss me or you're
just gonna I'm Gonna Roll Up and then
you're Adam like a predator oh boom boom
it's fast it's fast like a couple
punches out yeah we're just one left
hook to you you're not used to being
punched in the face no no no I don't
like that yeah I've been punching
something I don't like it or if I take
you to the ground you're gonna be like a
fish out of water you're gonna be on the
ground you're gonna put your hands up
right
you're done as soon as you do that
you're done you know Jujitsu is a scary
thing to know
you know but nowadays you know because
of UFC a lot more people are are pretty
you know
are pretty good at it yeah so you never
know who you're gonna you know but
here's the deal if you're a martial
artist if you're a fighter a martial
artist or a fighter certainly a
professional fighter
that's the last thing you want to do
you're not you're you're trained not to
fight exactly you know what I mean it's
it's always the like the Goombas in New
York you know they take their shirt off
somehow and they want to fight you with
no shirt on like there's always those
guys that I'm like God I just want that
guy to get their ass kicked they do they
eventually do like somebody's gonna get
you made up have you ever had anybody
work you work with on set you don't have
to say the name obviously but somebody
like he needs to be smacked around a few
times
how do you keep your cool because you're
a tough guy well you don't you don't
like people getting picked on you don't
like yeah you don't like bullies you
don't like you know you just walk over
to him and say hey man we're done let's
just go outside
nobody just me and you will go outside
like to talk yeah no no no we'll go
outside you know you want to be this way
we'll go outside you've said that oh
what are they probably more times than
they've never done it never never when
you say that no 99 of the people out
there do not want an altercation nor do
I I mean I don't you know I don't train
to be to fight in the street like I
train because I love it like I love yeah
I love absolutely I have no I have so
much respect for Fighters
um you know like I see some of these
women who you want to talk about going
against your nature no yeah they are um
and they're so because women don't have
the egos that men have so they learn
like that they're some of these women
are phenomenal Fighters yeah that is
awesome I know we you know it's funny we
haven't even talked to career at all who
cares no but I love it look I had it I
got to bring this up because it's one of
my good friends Scott Khan I I just
interviewed JK Simmons oh you did I got
Frank Grillo here one day as a lion yeah
Scotty Khan how about that man he's he's
just like one of those guys he just
wants to work wants to write wants to do
he's always got his hands in it and I
love that he wrote this movie I love
that he got such a great cast it's such
a throwback it's got comedy in it it's
like one of these it's you haven't seen
it yet it just came out and Scotty
somehow is really funny and and just
like vulnerable and like you like him
which is it's so important I know and
and uh I said to him I go and and I said
brother I don't want you to take this
the wrong way
you are so much like James Khan like
who's one of my favorite actors ever oh
yeah and he was just the one I just
talked to him about it all yeah I'm like
brother you kind of walk like him your
shoulders are like him your hairy like
them you have that charm like he had do
you know what I mean he's got there's a
toughness and he wasn't always like that
Scott like maybe he was fighting against
it I don't know it's funny you say that
because I told him I go I knew you from
back then I we were friends you just
there's a d it's it's a great but like
there's it's a different like a presence
I know man it is it's something it's
it's crazy he's come into his own and
he's so he's a really talented writer
like he's a really Talent writer and
humble like he's super humble guy man
like when I saw the movie and and all I
could think about was how happy I was
for him yeah I was like man I'm this is
great and the performances your
performance and JK and freaking I mean
everybody George Carroll is like it's
like everybody's good and everybody has
the part that opening scene in the movie
I talked about last time is just like
whoa whoa what and all of a sudden the
the wait the Cook gets shot in the neck
and you're like whoa what just happened
but she's great all the women were yeah
all the women are great Taryn Manning
yeah yeah and it's like and you play
you're like the Hitman who via George
I'm the Goomba yeah like you guys yeah
yeah do you love playing characters like
that I do I don't get a chance to play
them like that a lot I've never really
played Italian guys but John Schwab who
directed it I I've made five I've made
all his movies with him what oh yeah
yeah I've done every movie with him so
he's my guy
um so when he when he spoke to Scotty I
go he goes Scotty wants to know if you I
go yes send me the script and I read I'm
like this is fantastic so it really came
together in an interesting way and uh I
don't get to play Italian kind of Goomba
guys I don't know why I mean if you
could do it yeah and it's fun if you had
to do it you know I know that the guy I
played is my every one of my father's
friends
they're all idiots yeah they all think
you know I mean again emotionally
unstable guys always you know frustrated
and you know anyway I was born in Long
Island Oceanside Long Island oh you were
yeah but I grew up in Indiana from eight
on but like my whole family's New
Yorkers Bronx you know right all that
[__] Long Island and I remember one time
I was I was staying with my grandma for
the summer and my my dad my mom came to
visit it was her mom my dad my mom's mom
and my grandma Ruthie I have a tattooed
somewhere but she's uh she was the
toughest you don't [__] with her right
he didn't [__] with her she'd go if you
don't like you get the hell out of my
house
get out she threw a bone at my sister's
head like crazy so we're there one time
at Christmas my parents come to visit
and there's a the doorbell rings and I
go down and it's Anthony Pellegrino from
across the street I might have told the
story and he goes and he's got these two
kids in the headlocks he goes Michael
these two [__] were jumping on you
to sell
what do you want me to do with them and
I go what because they were jumping on
your [__] to sell I was having a
workout across the street and I you know
his mother was chicky Pellegrino oh I've
had chickies in my life and I said I
said Dad come here he's like what is it
you know comes down sees these two kids
that had a leg goes hey Mark what do you
want me to do with these guys they were
jumping on your sons to sell and he go
we go out to the car and there's no
dents or anything and I go uh you know
you guys are [__] idiots just just
get the [__] out and and everything was
calm and all of a sudden my grandmother
out of the blue comes with this giant
tree branch whacks this kid in the head
you pieces
when my grandson
and I'm like oh my God but I know that
New York mentality you don't [__] with
us no man you know it's just like oh
yeah and I grew up with a lot of kids
you know my family and uh animals you
know and we would beat the [__] out of
each other all day long our fathers
would beat us up like we you know we
were like Mad Dogs but if one of us was
in a fight with one of the neighbors
the whole all of us were you know you
don't touch my brother you know like you
don't touch you remember those oh they
were great they were lawn chairs oh yeah
the old remember the launch yeah with a
little uh yeah what you sit on is real
cheap well [__] like crisscross
stitching like the you know the the amp
amp you might even yeah exactly or maybe
wall bounce
what else was that listen my mother she
you know they loved coffee and cake you
know who's coming over for coffee of
course coffee cake coffee cake and so
they had Entenmann's
but my mother would go to the uh this
the Entenmann's next day store where
where where this
it was literally a store dedicated to
cake that was like a day before it was
gonna be stale
she'd also come home from the amp where
the meat was just about Brown oh man
because it was
cheaper man yep you know it's so funny
um I mean I I can talk about the The
Purge movies are you gonna do any more
Purge movies they got one written James
demonico it's from Staten Island
um you've done two I've done two with
with him who created it and then he then
he just produced the rest of them but
he's got a the last one which is just
about my character all written all done
but Blum and Universal and Michael Bay
they have to kind of figure out when uh
but you're gonna do it again yeah I
would definitely man I you know I love
those movies do you love uh it's all
those are hard work right it is you're
always fighting you're always fun though
you love that I love it I've done so
many and they probably go Frank what do
you think yeah right right yeah we love
it I got this idea I love I did a movie
a little while back with my partner Joe
carnan uh called boss level and it was
me and Mel Gibson and me watts and I'm
basically all and on every I'm I'm on
every shot of the movie but I did all my
it's it's I relive it's like Groundhog
Day meets die hard I I kind of read it
and I did all of my own everything and I
had the most fun boss level is it good
it's phenomenal it's on Hulu you got
boss level one day as a lion oh no that
I have like 60 movies that I've done
yeah I saw something like that you have
like all these freaking I mean I mean I
don't do everything yeah I know I gotta
stop I have to stop for a while hold in
front with Jason stay though I mean come
on yeah yeah yeah oh it's fine but you
know look I'm Blue Collar guy you put
your shoes on and go to work you know
and in the last five years they've been
paying me money that I never thought I
would make so you take advantage of it
yeah I mean how long are they gonna pay
me you know what I mean it's like I
don't know probably forever no probably
not no what's gonna happen is this Frank
gorilla is one of those guys that people
know either the Marvel movies and all
that how many Marvel movies have you
done three okay
Winter Soldier now I'm doing DC now
you're doing this crossover yeah that's
right what gun wait what'd you do with
gun no I'm about to oh you can't say it
no I just got hired so you can't say
what you're doing no you can't say the
project no because I get in trouble
because there's a million projects who
knows what it is right right it's their
first yeah
yeah well as long as you're not playing
[__] Lex Luthor I'm not playing like
slow there only one person could play
that's true he's doing a completely
different version because he's like are
you gonna play you're good friends with
James you know James is a very close
friend of mine I'm like dude he's got a
whole new thing figured out there's like
a whole no I'm not like if he wants to
give me your wall let me give me a ride
I'm the same way I'm one of my best
friends if you you know what I could do
right if you want to hire me hire me I'm
not going to sit here I don't do that
[__] I'm not begging for fun I don't
know I have oh grudges but no no no I
don't I mean I mean the Marvel movies I
mean do you find look I obviously
probably can't say but do you think like
you know back in our time where it was
like Raiders the loss came right this
Lost Ark came out yeah you know and then
you had to wait two years for Temple of
Doom or Star Wars came out and then
three years for I love that I loved the
waiting and the anticipation and but now
it's like almost every weekend there's a
million kill listen I first of all I
don't know I don't know what covet has
done to the movie business but you know
when I did Captain America Winter
Soldier Marvel was not they had done and
by the way people love that that's a
great movie right as a movie itself not
as a Marvel yeah it's a great movie also
Logan yes yeah I didn't see it but the
people told me Logan it's fantastic yeah
it's very dark it's really cool yeah
um and so it was Winter Soldier but you
waited for the next like and then all of
a sudden Marvel blew up and you know now
so many different directions now it's
all over the place now almost seems like
it's all the same so who cares you got
to make it special yeah you know what I
mean so I think they need to kind of and
I think they are I think that now
they're gonna put out less how about
three movies a year yeah you know three
great movies a year thank you thank you
and by the way they got to be careful
with the Star Wars it's everywhere too
there it's like it's over the place yeah
and what happens they get backlash they
mandalorian's brilliant right but then
you got the other series that are just
like oh this and this and I'm not saying
I hate them but like solo and all these
other but to me I'm a giant Star Wars
fan I'm like don't care I don't care
don't care man Lauren I finally care
right right just make let John Favreau
be in charge of everything there you go
John Favreau by the way brilliant he's
brilliant yeah I love John Favre yeah
he's he he directed my favorite movie
ever let me guess elf yeah I love it
Jimmy Khan Jimmy Khan
see that movie made me cry when I had to
slay when it comes at the end I [__]
cried it elf I know
I cried at L okay no by the way I took
my kids to see Dungeons and Dragons I
heard it's good Chris Brian's really
great I hear it's good but at the end
Dungeons and Dragons
um
you cried I was crying you got that Gene
from your dad no that's what you got you
know [__]
um touched on everything I mean you work
with Ryan Reynolds and Sam Jackson I
punched Ryan Reynolds in the face by
accident yeah that didn't feel good no
so there's a scene where it's Ryan and
Sam and Selma and we have them uh tied
up their hands behind their back and I'm
coming in to interrogate him I'm from
bomb the detective and I got it he's
he's doing his thing where he yaps you
know and I punch him in the face right
so I take a swing and he goes do not
punch me in the face I go brother I've
been boxing since I'm 11. I'm not gonna
punch in the face just don't lean in
First Take
I clip them right
like not all contact but a little
contact I hit him you grazed him I hit
him yeah I hit him and he's and did you
Brian Glazer him yes or was it no one no
no no no no I graze him and he and but
that's the day that they kept in the uh
was he pissed no no he was a good sport
about it he's like what the [__] I made
29 million a movie what are you doing
yeah
oh my God who do you get Starstruck do
you get Starstruck anymore you've worked
with everybody you know I do get Star
Struck and I like that I get Stars me
too you know I become friend it took me
a minute I become friends with Stallone
called me and I worked with him on
Gardens two and three right I became
like very very friendly once he's great
right yeah he called me up because he
wanted to redo Nighthawks as a team I
love that movie so he said you know I
think uh you played my role and would
find a new Rutger hour and I direct I
went well let me think about it okay
yeah and uh and then he went and did
Tulsa Kings but anyway I subsequently
became friends of mine go to his house
and and then you know like I'd go to his
house on the weekends and and we'd be up
there just the boys and it would the
boys are you know me
um Stallone Dolph Lundgren Dolph Arnold
Pacino Sugar Ray Leonard uh Bill Burr
all in the room all in the room just
hanging out hanging out did you feel
comfortable well I was like you know at
one point we were watching the Canelo
fight and and Sugar Ray is here in
Pacino who's holding my arm like an old
Italian man you know like we're in we're
locked like this uh and they and they're
they're showing a a
a flashback of Ray Leonard's fight
against Tommy Hearns on the fight and
he's sitting next to me and Pacino's
leaning over laughing and I'm like this
is ridiculous this is like you know you
used to have those I used to have those
dreams like about Frank Sinatra like I'd
be hanging out with Frank Sinatra and
then wake up and go wow I was hanging
out with Frank Sinatra in my dreams I it
felt surreal did someone take a picture
of that yes I have pictures Stallone
took pictures they put that on his
Instagram you send me that picture and
I'll post it when your interview comes
out of you in the gang yep I had golf on
the podcast he's crazy oh he's brilliant
I did a little movie with him what'd you
do I just jumped for one day he they
asked me to
um against my agents um wishes
um but he played this uh this uh
commander of some U-Boat it wasn't an
action movie and it was based on some
real life event and I just played like a
an American General uh for a day
um it was it fun it was fun and of
course I was on the poster
like what are you doing dude like you
know you're every time because what
happens at this point now every time I
put myself on a movie I get diluted it
dilutes so then if they're out there
selling another movie and they want me
to be in it they'll go I like he's got
that and that coming out we're not in
the Frank Grillo business this week yeah
because I feel like you're the kind of
guy that if you didn't have somebody
watching your back like that you'd be
like yeah right you're just a regular
guy I do I'll do your move sure yeah
when we show you yeah yeah you know I I
was like that for a long time until I
was like uh most of these movies aren't
good right I can't do this right it hurt
me it's actually hurt my career no I
don't think I think you're the kind of
guy that honestly
people want to be around you look at
pachina look at Salon inviting new
things people want to be in business
with you you're fun to work at you're a
tough guy you're a cool guy uh you got a
good head on your shoulders uh you're
open and honest you don't see that a lot
right it worked you know what you're
doing they can rely on you and I think
there's not a doubt like like one
movie's gonna hit where everybody sees
it and go who's Frank
grillo's been here for fun yeah I know
you know what I mean yeah I know that's
what happens where you're like dude this
guy's been awesome have you seen this
have you seen that like oh what yeah you
know what I mean you're yeah it's fine
you know look I have a fun career it's
you know uh I get to slide in and out of
things and and uh I get paid pretty well
but uh yeah it's it's funny because
you go along like my friends run that
show billions and and I'm friends with
Giamatti I went and I was going to do a
couple of episodes
I got the best story about Paul Giamatti
walking in my hotel room while I'm naked
with a woman in a bed no yeah ask him
about it you know Paul very well say
Paul Michael Rosen my friend I just do
this podcast he was telling me a story
where you walk in at Sundance and they
gave you his room key and you brought
all your luggage and he looks at me and
goes oh oh wow wow
great job all right uh and I go uh yeah
yeah he walked out and the next day he
was doing press night Bonnie goes oh
wait a minute wait a minute excuse me oh
my God
like he goes on there can I tell the
story I'll tell everybody I can tell it
I don't care ask him about it he'll
never forget it it's amazing he'll never
forget that that's amazing she wasn't
completely naked by the way not a bad
boxer really little known fact sounds
like a box you know Paul Giamatti yeah
he'll [__] kick your ass uh this is
called uh [__] talking with Frank Grillo
this is my top tier patrons they it's
rapid fire you answer quickly if you
want to talk for a little more than a
second okay whatever but it's like boom
right uh Patron support the podcast love
you uh patreon.com inside you thank you
I love you guys here we go Maya P what
is the biggest misconception people have
about you uh that I'm a tough guy
right I don't know first thing I said I
I don't know him he could be he could be
a tough guy like I'm gonna answer that
[__] question who the [__] are you
Charlene C been a fan since you played
heart Jessup on Guiding Light wow how
did you like working on a soap opera
some actors kind of look down on it
after they hit hit it big While others
embrace it I loved it I loved it it's
where I met my wife and uh uh it was
great training and discipline and and uh
listen man you know again I'm blue color
I had a job
that's right yeah and by the way how
hard is it learn all those lines you do
you know of script today
I can never do it yeah I really could
never do it and I'm not that good
looking great h
what do you do to relax get in a fight
no it's funny you say that I train I
fight yeah I box uh boxing because it's
repetitive motion it's very Zen eye box
and it does relax man do it every
morning if I miss it my days off and you
probably can't sleep well no I mean I I
train every day
no matter what if you're working 14
hours a day you train on a train and
it's built now it's built into my
contract that I have to go to the gym in
the morning so the day needs to start at
seven instead of six yeah do you
um still someone with your stamina and
your like endurance do you still get
tired during the day or are you always
full energy uh I have a lot of energy
but I've always been that way always
once in a while I'll close my if I sit
down I'll I'll take a nap for 15 minutes
and I'm up and I'm you know back at it
but I do everything at my house like I'm
I'm I don't sit still my my son put a
test to it I mean you you can't put a
cup down without me coming by picking it
up OCD oh yeah me too do you stress
still do you get anxiety still yeah do
you I do I you know I do I worry about
my kids a lot but I have overall you
know I I grew up with no money and I'm
always worried that the ice cream is
gonna melt and I'm not gonna have any
money and I'm gonna have to sell my
house you know I you know I I'm always
worried yeah like old school if my phone
doesn't ring for a week and I don't a
movie off from um that's it it's over
you know what I mean you still have that
which I don't mind because it keeps you
I think a little bit of anxiety is good
I'm neurotic in a way that
I'll call my business manager every
month once for an hour face time I guess
here it comes and I go
if I just didn't do anything
how long could I survive he's like
you're not doing this I know because you
go I go why because I just want to know
right can I live a year five years what
is it he's like don't get married I'll
tell you that
Sophie M can you tell us something fun
behind the scenes stories from your time
on Prison Break
ah Prison Break fun stories
um all of the actors were deathly afraid
of all the real convicts that they were
working with or around because it was a
functional prison and uh they weren't as
tough as you thought they were really
yeah yeah
they were like little school girls with
their lunches like getting cat calls by
by real prisoners did you work with Bill
fickner uh and yeah a little bit I did a
good friend of mine he was in the
podcast great accurate I worked for them
too he's great he's great yeah Nico P
what type of characters are you most
drawn to I'm drawn to dark uh you know
troubled you know I don't know
anti-heroes you know those those kind of
uh you know not those classic kind of
Charles Bronson kind of characters
what's your favorite movie of all time
yeah favorite movie of all Rocky no I I
it's probably the movie I've watched the
most there's two of them it's probably
either The Godfather or heat
really yeah I never really got in the
heat but I only saw it once a long time
ago should I revisit it yeah revisit it
it's that good it's that it's that good
did you see the new Top Gun one of my
favorites I loved it I went I don't even
remember liking the first Top Gun this
one's amazing how about this a 61 year
old white guy brought the movie business
back to the uh back on its feet and then
then Keanu about to be 60. just killed
it again like it's it's it's nice to see
these guys have you worked with him not
Keanu I did a movie with him and he's
the nicest guy everyone says it and I
would walk up to him every day and drag
and be like I can too he's like hello
how are you that's how he is and I'm
like I'm good I'm like I'm like great
it's gonna be a great day isn't it
because well I hope so
okay all right this is great
all right what do we do now
um Zero Dark Thirty End of Watch wheel
man uh the boss level which you said I
have to see yeah it's fun remind me I'm
watching the boss level and one day as a
lion yeah Scotty come on man got it you
got to see this movie it's so much fun
and it's like it reminded me of like a
little Tarantino ask the comedy kind of
thing and the way it's shot I just
really enjoyed it and by the way mate
you know this is the great thing if you
really love movies made for you know on
a shoestring budget supporting yeah just
bringing your friends in to make a movie
and and doing it for the right reason
and it it really I would went they
screened it at CAA and I was like wow
that's as much better than I would ever
imagine it to be you know so great
filmmaker John Schwab and and phenomenal
Scott Com or your uh parents both proud
of you
they yeah my mother you know I was on
the cover of those soap opera magazines
every week oh she loved that and I might
as well have been Carrie Grant my mother
didn't know the difference between a
soap opera a sitcom or a movie like it
doesn't matter it's all the same right
it's all the same so she'd be you know
getting groceries and there would I
would be you know usually shirtless on
the cover of soap opera magazine or soap
opera weekly and that when my mother
would say that's my son this is my son
he's a star I'm like what about your dad
not until he saw the gray I flew them
out to the premiere of the gray and my
father was bawling and uh he could
barely speak to me like he had no clue
that I like did he give you a hug oh
yeah he was and and you know at that
Premiere like everybody was you know
Liam and Bradley Cooper and all of our
friends that like that was a big deal
that and that that wasn't that many
years ago before he passed like no
because right now the gray was 11 years
ago it was yeah it feels like it was
just out like five years ago it's
because we're getting old
[__] you
um I love it man you seem like I mean
you got the world the world is your
oyster buddy I love it I love it I know
you I want don't you want to hang out
with this guy now brother I live five
minutes away don't say your address but
we gotta totally hang out I have movie
Nights in my screen I got all this [__]
I'm in I'm usually alone but you know or
with my kids so I don't I don't love it
I don't I love Remy too what are your
other kids names Liam after Liam Neeson
really
before I met Liam Neeson uh real quick I
took my pregnant wife at the time to see
The Crucible on Broadway with Liam
Neeson and Laura Linney and I'm a father
junkie like I always I'm always looking
for who could have been my father right
right and out comes this gigantic
beautiful Liam Neeson and I watch and
it's one of my favorite plays and I
watch him and I look at my wife who's
half Irish and I go we're naming the kid
Liam so we name him Liam after Liam
Neeson right years later I do worry I
get a call from Joe carnan I got a movie
called The Gray no matter what your
agents say you're in this movie just
know this right calls me up and goes I
want you to come and sit with me and
Liam I said Liam who he goes Liam Neeson
he's playing that way so I go up and I
meet with them we get shit-faced and
it's a little bar on the Upper West Side
by his house and at like four o'clock in
the morning I said I gotta tell him
story about my kid and then as I'm
telling her I'm going is this going to
sound weird like am I going to sound
like a stalker like is this gonna and as
I'm telling them he starts to cry
and so it choked him up he's a very
emotional guy yeah you've got Liam
Neeson to cry because he named your kid
out and then Liam Neeson had my my
mother and my kids come to Canada when
we were shooting to Greg because he
wanted to meet Little Liam and and I got
pictures of my mother fawning overly at
least you know I still remember him and
Schindler's List oh my God at that end
scene I'll still ball when he's like at
the very end he sees the people he saved
but the people he could have saved he
starts to think about he's like
look at this
it's raining yeah yep could have saved
yep
I could have saved so many and he starts
to lose
I know
yeah you're gonna do your boxing puzzle
like why not
um this has been freaking amazing yeah
bro you're so easy to talk thanks for
having me really thanks for coming out
yeah good luck with everything I wish
you the best I'm gonna call Gunn after
this and talk about what projects it is
um and uh cool yeah you're coming back
yeah come back love love all right love
and come to my house too I have fight
nights and stuff yeah absolutely and by
the way John Bernthal you know him yeah
he's a tough guy too right good guy yeah
he's a tough one yeah he knows how to
box like he won't he he'll he won't back
down no that guy seems pretty tough yeah
he's and he's great I love Johnny and I
I've know I've watched his career we
were going to do a movie together a long
time ago I became buddies with him but
then we did a conic we did a Comic-Con
together for whatever he was I think he
was on the the zombie Walking Dead yeah
yeah yeah and uh I just love him I mean
you know who would win in a fight
between you two you're 58 57 57 how old
is he he's probably 40. does age have to
do anything with it not really
they say 50 is good for a fighter you
got that old man kind of girl toughness
yeah like what are you gonna do are you
in back down from from a fight from
Johnny no he went back down for you
either no I wouldn't expect him to he's
just stuck I back down from both of you
no yeah back down from your kids I'm not
fighting anyone well if you won't accept
him except all right love everybody
thank you love you man
great guy he's easy to talk to and you
know I honestly
I wish I was as Fearless as he is when
it comes to like
if you fear someone or walking down a
dark alley or what you don't want to
bump into him
if you're looking for a fight you don't
want to bump into Frank Grillo because
he doesn't care he's not scared that
fear is gone he's done so much training
and work and fighting that that's past
him
and if someone thinks they could you
know look at him go oh [__] this guy
they're in trouble
they're gonna probably they're most
likely gonna be in trouble he is a you
could just tell the relaxation when you
ask him are you worried about it nah I
don't get worried about that stuff well
somebody just you know wants to fight he
was like yeah most most people don't
know how to fight so I I know exactly
what to do I'll probably take five
seconds in the fight I'm like oh my God
don't want to mess with that guy uh
thank you for listening love you long
time patreon.com inside of you join
patreon become a patron and help support
the podcast which all these people do
these are the top tiers
um
yeah tons of benefits by joining patreon
if you don't know
um
you get a box from me every three or
four months you get a little notes from
me you get an occasional Zoom uh YouTube
lives uh shout outs on the podcast your
name shouted out yeah I get to ask
questions
um Ryan by the way you were in England
I was in England again it's like your
fourth time I I mean I I've been many
times do you like it did you find
something fun to do I love it uh I mean
I'm half English
do you know that really yes
so all my my summer vacations like we'd
for a long time we'd go visit my mom's
family in the north of England and they
all speak English British either from
Yorkshire
that's how they talk from the north
North the north the north the north but
yes but it was just in London and um
yeah no it's like it's like going home a
little bit like I I feel a kinship I
like that and so I do I like uh I like
walking around London I get like a few
hours to myself to just
Mill around the city and London's a
great place to do that and I walked
around and I got on random trains got
off and found stuff to do was great you
know with me
you know there are those people that
explore like my friend John he heater
loves to just he could just be by
himself and explore and final cool stuff
and
I don't like that I prefer having
someone who lives in the area take me
around and show me around and show me
the cool places and what to do uh I
don't like to be sort of on my own I'm
just I'm not that person I just like I
I'm like I don't want to get lost I
probably will uh yeah but you know your
way around a little bit I I didn't know
where I was at all
um I had no really no but I but I felt
comfortable enough and confident enough
and it was it was sort of good to yeah
to remind myself of uh that I have the
ability to uh and the confidence in
myself to to get around and figure it
out maybe I should do that more just so
you know either a mess up also there are
apps there's GPS apps you just plug in
where you need to be and you and it'll
figure it out for you so as far away as
I I got from the people that I knew like
when it's still okay I was gonna be fine
yeah you still were okay I still were
okay still we're okay north north from
the north North Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones Jon Snow top tier patrons Nancy
D Leah ass
little Lisa Yukiko Yukiko Jill e Bryan
hidden game Nico P Robert B Jason W
Sophie amaraj C Joshua D Jennifer Ann
Stacy l
what's that Stacy song Stacy's Mom it's
got it going on
Stacy's Mom's got it going Stacy's mom
has got it going on just all I wanna
waited for so long I know the words
because it came out when I was in high
school all right
can't you see Jamal F Janelle B uh Mike
E El Don Supremo good talking to you on
a zoom the other day with Welling we had
a nice Zoom with him uh 99 more Santiago
am loved the statue the statue in the
wide shot you can see it I have it he
sent me it it's the best gift ever uh
it's it's awesome it's creepy looking at
me but it's cool Chad W Lee NP Janine R
Maya P Maya
you got your box okay Maddie s Belinda n
Santiago your box keeps getting sent
back
three times now so we got to figure that
out dude because
you know the first two times I paid
extra for shipping to ship it to
Argentina but now it's come back a third
time another box when we have the right
address I don't know what's going on
Santiago talk to Bryce I just dropped a
coin
Maddie s Belinda and Dave H hello Dave
it's Dave Dave H how are you Dave I love
Dave I'm trying to make you need toxic
but he's subtle very this is Jason
Statham is it Jason it's always you're
doing what are you doing he sounds like
a Jason Statham Dave H I like it what
are you doing Sheila G oh Oh Sheila Brad
d Ray harada tab of the T Tom and
Liliana a uh Talia M bet CD I miss you I
miss all you
Angel M ran and C Cory K Dev Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy see Brandy D Joey M
Eugene and Leah Corey Heather L Jake
Busey B Megan T Angela F uh Mel s
Orlando C Caroline R Christine s Eric H
Shane R Andrew M Tim l
Karina N I just sent some boxes to these
people
they should be receiving them soon
Amanda R gen B Kevin e Stephanie K jorel
jam and Jay Leanne J Cindy e Mike Epps
now we have we have uh two Leons now but
spelled differently Mike f
Stone H Miss s Brian L kdb Aaron R
Kendall l
can't forget house J Meredith I Charlene
C Kara C Mary R Sheena L Jessica B Kyle
F Marisol P Estevan G Kaylee J Megan K
Nikki L and Brian a welcome to the
newcomers thank you as always to the old
comers
is that what you'd say the old comers
well that sounds dirty sounds dirty
to uh my old friends
what was that movie who helped you
some old friends it's from The Exorcist
three
just not in the files all right uh thank
you for listening to this podcast and
making it your podcast I'm sure you have
others but thanks for uh your loyalty
and uh for Michael Rosenbaum in the
Hollywood Hills of California I am also
Ryan Taylor that's Ryan Tales little
wavy camera uh thanks guys thanks for
being here and uh always be good to
yourself be good to yourself no I mixed
it up you almost said the small almost
be oh what was it what be good to
yourself what was the other one always
hold on to small boy sold on a
Smallville
um yeah be good to yourself I'll see you
[Music]